the way to interpret this is not so much
as a huge increase in interest rates
this is part of a return to normality
normal interest rates in normal times
are are positive with respect to the
inflation rate they're above the level
of inflation if we think that the
inflation rate is going to be two
percent we would typically expect
interest rates to be three percent or
more we've had some very unusual times
in the last decade which has meant that
interest rates after the financial
crisis have hovered around zero that is
been
unprecedented in in in monetary history
so we should actually be reasonably
pleased that interest rates are going to
return to something like normality 1.75
is a start we'd expect a few more hikes
as well but given an inflation rate at
least temporarily in double figures
this is not in any world a set of tight
monetary conditions interest rates are
still low and have to go higher the
level is the thing that really matters
not the change and in a sense the npc is
catching up here and doing a reasonable
job in doing so yeah indeed because many
other central banks around the world are
raised ahead of our central bank being
the bank of england of course and what
does it say to you about how the
governor andrew bailey and the other
members of the monetary policy committee
all of whom of course get a chance to
vote every month what does it say to you
about how they are feeling
about the economy and the economic
prospects in the uk going forward well
again their focus will always be on
delivering price stability defined by
the government as two percent subject to
not injecting too much output volatility
which is another way of saying having a
deep recession where unemployment rises
we'd prefer a more gradual increase of
inflation back to target rather than
something that was very rapid and led to
lots of people losing their jobs which
we don't want to see in an economy we
want people to be able to work uh and
earn a living so i i think the npc would
have taken a step back and said look
where are rates now 1.25 where do we
think inflation is going to be two years
ahead and where do we think interests
have to get to and i suspect
collectively they've taken the view it
has to get to around three percent um
over the course of this year or early
next year and they have to think
carefully about how to
move in the appropriate steps to get
there personally i would favor a more
gradual increase in interest rates but
what really matters is that is the final
level they reach and i think something
around three percent is the right level
and the reason i prefer a bit more
gradualism is that we don't exactly
understand how the economy will respond
it's a heavily indebted economy public
debt is about the size of gdp uh
household debt is also similarly about
the size of gdp and therefore these
interest rate rises may have more of an
impact than we might think and it might
take might make sense to move more
slowly than quickly but what matters is
getting three percent today with uh some
more breaking news coming through from
the bank of england um the uk they say
will enter five consecutive quarters of
recession with gross domestic product
falling by as much as 2.1 what do you
make of that well that's very much in
line with what we were discussing a few
moments ago the increase in oil prices
the increase in food prices
and the overall disruption to uh the
supply chains the uk is a
global and open economy is particularly
affected by these things as is our
tourist and recreational sector and we
ourselves didn't see much opportunity
for growth over the next year and a half
and i think the bank has followed a very
similar narrative this is a contraction
in activity that is sustained across
many sectors that means we're going to
be materially poorer in a year than we
might have anticipated some time ago
and what is this going to do for
sentiment i mean you've got a
double-edged sword here haven't you
you've got a prediction from the bank of
england of five consecutive quarters of
recession as soon as you say that word
everybody starts to panic and you've got
inflation rising i mean it's it's not
it's not appealing in any way is it no
no i mean stagflation has always been uh
portrayed as the central bankers
nightmare scenario and this is certainly
the most testing period the independent
central bank with his monetary policy
committees had to face since the
financial crisis and arguably including
that as well we had developed some tools
during the financial crisis to deal with
that that avoided a deep and prolonged
recession but now we have as you say
both inflation rising and output falling
but we can understand well why output is
falling for the reasons i've given a
large amount of the
goods and services that we have to buy
in from abroad have gone up in price um
and it's also the case that our trade
has compressed as a result of brexit and
and tourism is not back to the levels
that it that it was
uh pre-covered all of that means the
economy is going to contract and be uh
not as productive or not as large as it
as it might have been anticipated some
years ago
that's in a sense going to take care of
itself what the bank has to focus on is
is bringing that inflation rate down in
a gradual manner so it doesn't
exacerbate the downturn in the economy
the downturn as we've said is a result
of things that are happening mostly in
the rest of the world what the bank has
then to do is just
you know squeeze some of the demand out
of the economy so inflation returns
gradually to target